so let's say s is the value that this
infinite series converges to we're going
to assume that this series actually
converges
and the the definition of the series
each term is going to be a function of n
we're going to assume that this is the
same type of series that we looked at
when we looked at the integral test or
namely that this function is a
continuous positive decreasing function
over the interval that we care about so
it is continuous
it is positive
and it is
decreasing this isn't saying continuous
plus decreasing it's let me just write
it that way continuous
positive
positive
and it is decreasing so it could be a
function that looks something like this
now my goal of this video is to put is
to see if we can estimate a range around
us and this is going to be very useful
because we've seen some infinite series
where we are able to figure out what
exactly does it converge to but you can
imagine there are many many many more
where we're not going to be able to
figure out exactly what it converges to
and instead we're going to have to do it
using a computer or by hand and in those
cases it's good to know how good our
estimate is and we also want as good of
an estimate as possible with as little
computation as possible so let's think
about how we can do that
well the way to tackle it you could
imagine is let's split this up this
infinite sum let's split it up into the
sum of a finite sum
so let's say the first k terms so n
equals 1 to k
of f of n so this is very computable if
k is low enough you could probably even
and if f is a simple enough function you
could probably do this by hand but you
could definitely do this with a computer
and then it's going to be that plus
plus an infinite plus another infinite
series but now you're going to pick up
at k plus 1 the k plus 1 term
and you're going to go to infinity of f
n
so if we could put some bounds on this
then that'll allow us to put some bounds
will allow us to put some bounds on this
right over here because this is just the
sum of the partial sum
of the partial sum of the first k terms
and the remainder that we get
after to to get us to the actual value
so you can see what kind of what's left
over after we take that partial sum and
this will be this is easier to write for
me than this right over here so the key
is can we come can we come up with some
bounds for this
and to do that i'm going to go to this
graph and use some of the same arguments
we use or the same conceptual ideas we
used for the integration test
if we there's two ways to conceptual
there's two ways to conceptualize what
the sum represents relative to this
graph as we'll see it can represent an
overestimate of of of the area between
some x value and infinity and it could
represent the underestimate of a
different region so let's look at that
so let's first think about let's first
think about the underestimate let's
think about the underestimate so if this
right over here let's say that this
right over here is k
actually let me do it in a color that
you let's let me do it in that
we're doing a yellow color so let's say
that this right over here is k
this is k plus 1
this is k plus that's going to be that's
let's do this is k plus 2
k plus 2 k plus 3 on and on and on so
one way to conceptualize
this sum right over here is it could be
the sum of the following rectangles
so the first term
is the this area the area of this first
rectangle
because this area is this area is height
or this rectangle's height is f of k
plus one
is f of k plus one and its width is one
so f of k plus one times one its area is
going to be f of k plus 1 which is
exactly this first term right over here
when n is k plus 1. and then the second
term by the same argument could
represent the area of this rectangle the
third term could represent the area of
that rectangle and we could just keep
going on and on and on and so what are
the what is the sums of these areas of
these rectangles or the sum of these
terms representing
well you could view it as an estimate
you could view it as an estimate of the
area under the curve between x equals k
and x equals infinity but it's going to
be an underestimate notice the these are
all completely contained in that area so
one way to think about it is that our r
sub k
our r sub k is less than or equal to its
underestimate for the area between x
equals k
between x equals k and infinity of f of
x
f of x dx
so that essentially puts an upper bound
that puts an upper bound on us and this
is already interesting because now we
can already say if s
so we know that s
s is equal to this
now if this is less than this thing
right over here we can say that s is
going to be less than or equal to
our
our partial sum
plus
plus
this thing plus the improper integral
from k to infinity of f of x
dx notice if this is equal to this and
now since this is less than this this
must be less than what we have on the
right hand side so just like that if
we're able to compute these two things
and we are often able to compute these
two things we're able to put an upper
bound on our actual sum
now what about placing a lower bound on
it well we could conceptualize the same
sum the same r sub k
instead
instead we can conceptualize it this way
where the first term here represents not
this rectangle but it represents this
rectangle notice it has the same height
but it's just shifted over one to the
right the second term represents this
rectangle the third term represents this
rectangle why does that make sense well
the area of this first rectangle this is
going to be its height which is f of k
plus 1 f of k plus 1 times its width
which is just 1. so it's just going to
be f of k plus 1. so this is the area
here is the first term the area here is
the second term area here is the third
term the area here is a fourth term one
way to think about it we just shifted
all of those yellow rectangles ones one
to the right but now this is
approximating a different region this is
approximating the area under the curve
not from k to infinity but from k plus 1
to infinity and instead of being an
underestimate it's an over estimate now
the curve is is contained within the
rectangles so we could say that r sub k
in this context when we conceptualize
this way is going to be greater than or
equal to the improper integral not from
k but from k plus 1
from k plus 1
to infinity
f of x dx
and what does that allow us to do
well this places a lower bound on this
which will also place the lower bound on
this
if this is greater than that
then this is going to be greater than
this replaced with the improper integral
so we can write that so s is going to be
greater than or equal to
s sub k
plus
plus
the improper integral from k plus 1 to
infinity
f of x
f of x dx now you might be saying hey
sal this looks all crazy you have all
this abstract notation here you've
introduced an integral sign this seems
really daunting but as we'll see in the
next few videos these are actually
sometimes fairly straightforward to
compute this can be very straightforward
to compute if our k is not too large if
it's even large a computer can do it and
that these we can actually often compute
sometimes numerically but even more
frequently and that kind of defeats the
purpose but we can also compute them
using our analytic tools do it using it
using i guess you could say the the
power of calculus and so what this this
allows us to do is put a pretty neat
band around what our actual value that
we converge to is and as we'll see the
higher our k the better an estimate we
get and the tighter a range of our
confidence for that estimate and another
way to write these two inequalities is
to write a compound inequality that s is
going to be less than or equal to this
business
it's going to be less than or equal to
this business
so copy and paste
and it's going to be
and s is going to be
greater than or equal to this business
so you can say this business is going to
be less than or equal to s
so let me just copy and paste that
so
copy and paste oops that's not what i
wanted to do
so copy
and paste
and we could write it just like that
and so the next series of videos we'll
actually apply this and we'll actually
we'll see that it's pretty
straightforward it looks a little
daunting right now